ROSS MCELROY: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I'd like to introduce you to our
session, which is YouTube
Android Player Tools, and we're
going to be talking
today about how to bring YouTube
to your Android apps.
I'm Ross McElroy.
I'm a YouTube mobile
engineer within
Google at Google London.
ANTON HANSSON: My name
is Anton Hansson.
I work together with Ross, and
I'll be doing our live coding
demo later.
ROSS MCELROY: So first off, I
thought just give a brief
rundown of some background on
both YouTube, and its history,
and its progression to mobile.
So we all know YouTube.
It's our favorite destination
for keyboard-playing cats, and
space cats, and skateboarding
dogs.
And of course, that's the way
it started, with a lot of
viral videos, amateur videos,
giving people the ability to
express themselves on the web.
But it's progressed into more
than that, and there's now a
wide range of content available
for watching any
kind of videos on YouTube.
So you can learn something new--
there's a huge variety
of lectures available, anything
from statistics to
quantum physics to cooking.
It's being used as a platform
for campaigning, for example,
in the recent Kony 2012 video
or the videos uploaded from
Egypt during the Arab Spring.
It's also a great platform for
surfacing new talent, new
music, anything from the next
greatest band demoing their
latest song in their garage to
official music videos from the
next superstars.
And people love watching
these videos.
There are absolutely massive
amounts of video playbacks
watched on YouTube.
There's over 4 billion
videos played back
every day on YouTube.
That's more than 1,000
hours of videos being
watched every second--
incredible amount.
And the catalog is growing
tremendously, as well.
Over 72 hours of YouTube videos
are uploaded every
minute, a huge amount of
additional content.
And of course, as the content
has changed, the way in which
we watch the content has
evolved, as well.
Originally, of course, it was
only PCs were the platform
which you could watch YouTube
videos on, the only thing
powerful enough.
With the rise of smart phones,
tablets, smart TV devices, a
lot more people are choosing
these types of devices to
watch their YouTube videos on.
And we're now around the world--
it's coming up towards
20% off all YouTube
video playbacks
happening on mobile devices.
In the USA, it's greater
than 20% already.
And in some countries, for
example South Korea, it's
already more than
the majority.
It's greater than 50%.
So I think it's clear that as
these devices become more
prevalent in the home and
people's pocket, this is going
to be the medium of choice for
people watching YouTube
videos, and it's going to be
the majority of viewbacks
happening on these mobile
smart devices.
One of the other great things
about YouTube, which helped
build its success in the first
instance, was its ability to
allow you to embed YouTube
videos in your own website.
So this allows you to have great
video content on your
website without having to
have the whole necessary
infrastructure for sharing
these videos.
However, there's not, up until
now, been a very satisfactory
option for embedding YouTube
videos in your mobile
applications.
And so that's what we're going
to talk about today.
So today we are introducing
and pre-announcing a new
YouTube Android Player API,
and we want to put
YouTube in your apps.
So there was an important thing
I said there, which is,
this is a pre-announcement, and
so all of these details
today are going to be
subject to change.
We're not going to be launching
for at least a
couple of months.
And we would encourage feedback
and suggestions and
future requests.
So if you have any comments,
please use the mics at the end
of the talk, or we'll be hanging
out at the YouTube
Developer Sandbox
after this talk.
You can come and talk
to us in person.
So saying that--
this pre-announcement--
you probably already have
a copy of it in your
pocket right now.
How many of you have the YouTube
I/O Companion app?
Any of you used live
streaming on it?
You've used the YouTube
Android Player
API, in that case.
Anton, you want to have
a look at what's going
on in another session?
ANTON HANSSON: All right.
Fingers crossed.
See what's on.
Here's a live session.
There we go.
Looks like they're
having fun there.
[APPLAUSE]
ANTON HANSSON: Static slide.
ROSS MCELROY: So I'm hoping
that we're going to be
interesting to you today, and
you'll not resort to watching
other sessions during the
middle of the talk.
But if you do, I'll at
least be happy that
you're using our tool.
So why do we want another
YouTube Player API?
So there's three options
available to you at the moment
to embed YouTube videos in your
apps, and they're not
terribly satisfactory.
So the first two involve
embedding a web view in your
app and using that--
using the standard web embeds
currently available.
The first web embed option is
the normal Flash-based embed.
So this was the traditional
web embed format from the
beginning of YouTube.
Unfortunately, it's not really a
very true mobile experience.
The buttons are not very easily
clickable on mobile phones.
It's not optimized for
a touch experience.
And also, of course, it uses
Flash, and not many devices
have Flash pre-installed.
And if Flash is not available,
it will end up using the
browser plug-in, which means
you have no access to the
player API yourself,
and you don't have
access to monetize content.
So overall, this is not really
a very good mobile
experience for users.
The second option is an
IFRAME-based embed.
So this is a newer embed option,
which has been made
available recently.
It offers HTML5 video, so it
can be played on devices
without Flash, and you can have
full access to the player
through an API.
However, of course, this is
embedded in a web view, and
therefore the API
is JavaScript.
And there's a kind of impedance
mismatch there
between the Java, which you're
writing, and the
JavaScript in the API.
It's also, unfortunately,
unsupported on some versions
of Android.
So this is not really a very
good mobile development
experience for you.
And the final option is what
most of you end up doing, just
throwing off an intent to launch
the YouTube video in
the native Android
YouTube Player.
So this is really easy to do.
You just need to create an
intent with the video ID, and
it gives a really native good
experience to users.
However, you can't embed it
within your own UI, and it's
fire and forget, of course.
You have no Player API access,
and the user ends up leaving
your app to view the video, and
will hopefully come back,
but there's no guarantee that
they're staying within your
application.
So this has been described
as a kind of out-of-body
experience by some
of our partners.
So no control in that option.
So this is why we're creating
the YouTube
Android Player API.
It's a native library
specifically designed for
Android devices, and it actually
makes use of a lot of
the same code used by the native
Android YouTube Player.
So you can take advantage of all
the development that has
gone into that player in your
apps, automatically.
It's been optimized for the full
range of devices that run
Android, from mobile phones,
tablets, and Google TV
devices, and it's been optimized
so that it works
well on each of them.
So for example, on Google TV, we
have a different controller
scheme which uses the
keyboard-based remote controls
rather than a touch-based
interface, because of course,
you don't have touch on a TV.
We have support for a very wide
range of Android platform
versions, right back
to version 2.2--
that's the Froyo release--
through Gingerbread, Honeycomb,
Ice Cream Sandwich,
and the recently released
Jellybean.
And so this captures over 90%
of the Android devices that
are out there already.
And we also wanted to make it
really trivial for people to
embed YouTube videos
in their apps.
So I'll go into more detail into
how the API works later
in the talk, but I just wanted
to give you a brief look at
embedding how it would work,
and these three lines are
really all that's needed
to launch a YouTube
video in your app.
We have a lot of extra support
baked into the library to make
sure you can have a really
good, polished app, and
everything can be taken
care of for you.
And we have good support for
full screen, orientation
changes, handling hiding of the
system UI at appropriate
moments in time and
restoring of that.
And so it just makes it an easy
experience for you to
embed it in your apps and
make it a polished app.
The YouTube videos look gorgeous
on the devices.
We support full HD up to the
amount of resolution supported
by the device.
And the quality control is kind
of automatically dealt
with by the API itself, so you
don't need to worry about
whether the quality
stream will be
playable on that device.
The library will take
care of that.
And it will also choose the
quality automatically based on
network conditions, so on a
mobile network, it will use a
lower quality stream so the
user gets video quickly,
rather than having to
wait to buffer.
And finally, it has
full support for
monetized YouTube content.
So this is an important
one for partners.
It means that you have a much
wider range of content
available to you.
You have available--
you can view all the content
that's been marked as
monetizable on YouTube.
And that also means that if
you're the content owner, you
can have an additional
revenue stream.
So if you own the content, and
you put the content in your
apps, then you will get the
advertisement revenue through
the views of that content using
this player API in the
apps you write.
Just to make something clear--
so this is a player API.
We also have a data API, and
that's a separate API.
The data API's been around for
a while, and that allows you
to search for videos, get
recommendations, find related
videos, and access video
metadata, things like that.
And once you've got that data,
then that's when you would use
this player API to
make the playback
experience really great.
So I would have recommended that
you went to the Master
the Latest YouTube Data API Code
Lab, but unfortunately,
that was just before
this talk.
If you can find online some of
the details of that, I'm sure
that would be very useful to
you, if you're writing a
YouTube app.
So we're quite excited about
this API, and we distributed
it to a couple of our
external partners.
They've only had a couple of
weeks access to this API, but
they've created some good demos,
and we'd like to show
you what people can
do with this API.
So first off, we have
Maria Ly, who's
co-founder of Skimble.
She'll be downloading their
app, Workout Trainer.
MARIA LY: Thanks, Ross, and
good afternoon, everyone.
Without a doubt, everyone wants
to live well and be fit,
but it's not always easy.
We lack guidance, motivation,
and constantly feel like life
itself gets in the way.
Fortunately, with the
proliferation of a variety of
Android devices, we can now
overcome these challenges in a
fun, dynamic, and social way.
At Skimble, we are developing
the next-generation fitness
experience for mobile.
Specifically, our latest
application, Workout Trainer,
provides thousands of workouts
on your mobile device.
Our application provides a
multimedia-rich experience to
take out the guesswork in
exercise, and our approach has
helped us organically grow to
be a top-three health and
fitness application
on Google Play.
Did you know you can literally
exercise anywhere you are?
You could be at home on the
couch, at the office, or even
at Google I/O. On that note,
everyone stand up.
Really.
Get off your seats and
follow along to this.
My co-founder, Gabe,
will cue us in.
GABE VANRENREN: All right.
We're going to start out with
some chest openers.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Stand or sit tall with your
arms in front, palm to palm.
Inhale and open your
arms out and back.
Feel your chest and shoulders
open up as you take in several
deep breaths.
Squeeze your shoulder blades,
return, and--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GABE VANRENREN: All right.
Let's do march in place.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Stand tall, and optionally
rest your hands on
the back of a chair.
March in place by lifting
your knees up high.
GABE VANRENREN: OK.
Some finger bursts
and stretches.
-Make tight fists
with your hands.
Quickly stretch your fingers out
as far as they will go and
hold for three counts.
Relax and return them
back into fists.
Repeat.
GABE VANRENREN: All right.
Shadow boxing.
MARIA LY: Good one!
-Stand in a boxer's stance
and start boxing.
GABE VANRENREN: And
be careful!
MALE SPEAKER: Pretend like you
are actually punching the
person in front of you.
GABE VANRENREN: And
last, let's do--
back handsprings!
But seriously, don't do this.
-Begin with raised arms and
perform a squat while swinging
your arms downward.
Lean backwards, arch your
back, and thrust back.
Flip over with locked
arms to the floor.
Swing your legs over and snap
them down on the floor.
GABE VANRENREN: All right.
MARIA LY: Thanks, Gabe.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GABE VANRENREN: Hey, no
good demo without a
little crash bug.
MARIA LY: You guys didn't
expect that
one coming, did you?
Thanks for your participation.
Feel free to sit down now.
And let me tell you a little
bit about the YouTube
integration we did within
in Workout Trainer.
We used the YouTube Android
Player API to instantly stream
all of our gorgeous HD exercise
video onto any
Android device.
During the workout, as you could
tell, we were able to
choose a variety of exercises,
and the API provided us with a
handy thumbnail view which
we could select from.
That makes our job a lot easier,
and we could focus
more on creating a great workout
experience, rather
than dealing with streaming
video, thumbnail creation, and
everything else that's
cumbersome with video.
Ladies and gents, life will
continue to get in the way,
and by today, you're probably
going to be sitting in your
chair for over six hours.
Fortunately, with Skimble's
Workout Trainer application
and its YouTube Android API
integration, the exercise
coaching you need to
get active is just
an Android tap away.
Amazing!
Thanks.
ROSS MCELROY: Thanks
very much, Maria.
Getting a room of Google I/O
attendees to do exercise--
I think that's almost more of
an achievement than Sergey's
parachute jump there.
So next up, we have Tony
Jacobs, who's SVP of
technology at Gloto.
And he's going to be demoing
the Gloto Designer.
TONY JACOBS: Thanks, Ross.
Hi, guys.
Gloto provides a self-service
consumer engagement platform
called Gloto Designer.
Fortune 500 brands, publishers,
and agencies use
this sophisticated web app to
engage their audience with
scalable mobile and
web experiences.
Our customers tend to demand
creative control over
absolutely everything
they release.
When working with YouTube, they
want their own videos in
their own context with their
own monetization.
Of course, they usually have
a tight budget and a really
short deadline.
This is why we built the Gloto
Designer, and more to the
point, the mobile uploader for
the Gloto Designer, that lets
us use our HTML 5 editor to make
it ridiculously easy--
very easy--
to create well-constructed
native apps to browse, record,
and upload videos to YouTube.
We've got a beta of the YouTube
Android API, and we
were able to play videos inline
and full-screen in the
app, and we were able to
do all this without any
out-of-body experiences.
Like the phrase.
It only took about a day
or so to get this
working, so Ross, Anton--
good job.
It was actually really,
really easy.
So we actually prepared a video
to kind of make this a
little bit easier
to understand.
That is not the right one.
There we go.
So we made a really easy way for
customers to build their
own amazing experiences and
apps right on the web.
So as you can see, we're
concentrating on all the
little details to make an
app feel just right--
press dates on buttons and
player controls and all that.
So you can see, it's just
playing right in the app.
So we log into the free Gloto
Designer, and we'll just have
a look and see what's
going on.
So as you can see, there's
quite a few options here.
We can build on the web,
we can build on mobile.
But here, we're going to make a
mobile uploader for YouTube.
That's why we're here.
So as always, we have, complete
creative freedom.
There's no templates forcing
the workflow.
We can drag, we can rearrange,
and just build it out.
And look, we have some
videos to browse.
And when we tap them, they
play and go full-screen.
Of course, you can embed videos,
you can change colors,
you can change backgrounds,
you can do
all of that fun stuff.
And we're just playing with the
buttons for now, just to
keep it quick.
And as always, it tends
to be pretty easy to
preview on the device.
Comes up.
As you can see, the
videos play.
Tap things, interact, and
actually move the system
around pretty well.
So we've built a bunch of
examples using this tool.
You can see some very different
layouts, color schemes.
It's really important.
There's no templates.
We're not forcing any
designs on anyone.
We're letting you have complete
creative freedom.
You can follow a brand
style guide.
You're not really concentrating
so much on
building an Android experience
as much as you're building a
consumer experience.
It's great for the consumers.
And a lot of different
options there.
So Gloto Designer is a free
way to build awesome
experiences very quickly, and
basically immediately test
them on your device.
And that's basically it.
ROSS MCELROY: Thanks
very much, Tony.
So last stop.
We have Raghu Bala, the CTO of
Source Interlink Media, and
he's going to be demoing
their app, Motor Trend.
RAGHU BALA: Thank you, Ross.
Can you guys hear me?
No?
OK.
Now it's better.
So I'm Raghu Bala.
I'm with Source Interlink
Media.
I'm the CTO.
And with me is Wayne May, one
of our Android developers.
Source Interlink Media is an
enthusiast media company.
We've got a number of brands,
some of which you guys might
be familiar with.
Among them, we have Motor Trend,
Hot Rod, Automobile,
Surfing, and so on.
These are brands that are loved
by enthusiasts who are
into action sports and outdoor
lifestyle and so on.
And one of the brands, Motor
Trend, we built a Google TV
app last year.
And recently, for this show, we
have done a prototype using
the latest Android Player API,
which we are going to
demonstrate here.
So before we begin, I want to
say that for a media company,
there are three elements that
are very important, first of
which is reach.
So Google TV is an important
platform for us, because it
enables us to distribute our
content and actually reach
consumers at their homes
on a big screen.
So that, in and of itself, is
an important element for us.
The second part of
it is engagement.
So once you reach the consumer,
the second thing is
to get them to consume your
content and come back and
revisit your sites and
your apps and so on.
So Google TV gives us a kind
of a platform where we can
reach out to consumers and so
on, and then engage them with
video content.
And we're going to see some
examples in a couple of
minutes here.
And then the final thing
is monetization.
So you've got hold of your
audience, they are consuming
your content, but you also
have to make some money.
So the Android Player API, what
it does for us is all of
these three elements.
We actually have an app that has
been performing very well
on Google TV.
It's in the Android Marketplace,
Google Play.
For about nine months, it's
been the top few apps
throughout.
And that's all [? doing ?]
in the marketplace.
This app has been built
in the last two weeks
using the new API.
So it's pretty, I'd say,
alpha-level application.
But we were able to get it up
and running pretty quick, and
that's a testament to how
easy the API is to use.
And so what I'm going to do is
highlight three features in
the API that were
relevant to us.
The first one is, you're going
to see on the left side, on
the left panel there,
a playlist.
So one can bring in YouTube's
playlist into your app easily.
And so we have set up a number
of playlists like Epic Drives,
Head 2 Head, things that are
relevant in the auto space.
Once you select a particular
playlist, then you get to see
thumbnails of videos that
are in that playlist.
And once you click a particular
video, what we did was--
this is the monetization
aspect.
So before playing the video,
we show you an ad.
And we did this inset view of
the video that's coming up
next and played the ad first on
full screen, and then jump
into the video next.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
---start small, usually with
"what if?" being the first
question brought about.
In my case, immediately after
the "what if" came, we drove,
and a Subaru BRZ.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAGHU BALA: And then finally,
one other element that is
interesting--
you want to go to the
widget that we did?
So on the desktop in Google TV,
one of the things that you
can do is create this widget.
And the interesting thing about
the widget is, normally,
if you don't have a widget, what
you have to do is, you
have hope that your consumer
comes back, goes into the app,
looks for new content, and then
launches that content.
So here with the widget, what
you can do is you can actually
notify the consumer
of latest content.
And that way, you can just click
on the video directly
and jump into the content
immediately without having to
navigate through the app
and so on and so forth.
So these are three features that
we used as part of this
quick two-week prototype
that we built.
ROSS MCELROY: Thank
you, Raghu.
Thank you very much.
So next off, I thought I'd just
go into a bit more detail
into how you can use the API to
embed YouTube in your app.
So the first thing you need to
do to use the API is register
for a YouTube developer key.
The website for this, a link to
it will be up on the Help
website once we've got the
API fully released.
But it looks something
like this.
You fill in details of your
app, and then once you've
saved the details, you'll have
a developer key listed here.
And so you use that
developer key to
initialize the YouTube API.
So once you've done that, the
easiest way to embed a video
into your app is to use
what we call a kind of
fire-and-forget playback.
So we've got an activity
called a YouTube Player
activity, and that will allow
you just to play a video in
full screen or in a kind of
lightbox mode without having
to worry about it very easily.
So here, we have fire-and-forget
playback.
This is all the code that you
really need for that.
So you first initialize the
YouTube library using the
developer key and your current
context, as we
talked about earlier.
And then, when you want to play
the video, you create an
intent using the
YouTubePlayerAct
ivity.createintent method, pass
it the video ID, and then
just start that intent, and
it'll start an activity that
plays the video full-screen.
Easy as that.
You can do a few more
things with this.
You can pass in a playlist or
list of videos, as well, give
it a particular start index that
you want to start from.
This will allow the users to
navigate through those with
onscreen Next and Previous
buttons on the videos.
And finally, we have
a lightbox mode.
So if you would prefer to have
it kind of appearing popping
out of your activity with some
of your activities showing
around the edges, you
can do that as well.
That was what was shown
in the first screen
shot I showed earlier.
So that's really how easy
it is to embed a video.
But of course, this is a
kind of very easy but
less flexible option.
You don't get to interact with
your UI using this option.
So we have another option, which
is to actually embed the
YouTube video within
your UI itself.
And to do that, we have
two classes--
there's the YouTube Player
fragment and a
YouTube Player view.
They're both very similar, but
one, of course, is a fragment,
and one is a view.
And there's some consequences
to that.
The fragment is the preferred
option for you to use.
We also have support fragment,
so if you need to use the
support library, you
can use that.
But if you can't do that,
then we have the
player view, as well.
I'll tell you about the
restrictions on that.
So to embed the YouTube Player
fragment, it's just a normal
view, so you can embed it in
your view hierarchy, as you
would any other view, and
your layout XML file.
So here, if we hide that, we're
embedding this fragment
into the layout XML, we're
giving it an ID, and then the
demo activity--
again, we would need to
initialize the libraries in
onCreate, but then when we want
to play a video, we can
find that fragment using
findFragmentByID, and then
load the video into it.
So here I'm casting this
fragment to YouTube Player.
That's an interface object,
which both the YouTube
Fragment and YouTube Player
View implement.
And that provides the interface
for all the API
access you might want for
playing the videos.
So playing, pausing, loading,
queueing up videos, skipping
through playlists, seeking
through videos.
I'll not go into all the
details, but the things you
would expect to be able to
do on a player view.
As I said, the other option is
for you to use a YouTube
player view.
Now, we need to control the
life cycle of the Player
views, and because of that, if
you're using a player view,
you have to extend the activity
that we provide as
part of the library.
So we provide this YouTube Base
Activity, and you need to
extend that rather than the
normal activity object.
Once you've done that, you can
create a new YouTube player
view, so that could be created
in your XML again, or here I'm
just creating it in code, and
then you need to register that
player view with the YouTube
Base Activity.
So you can't make any
calls on the Player
before you've done that.
It's not initialized until
you've done that.
Once you've done that, it will
act exactly the same way as a
You Tube player fragment, and
you can load videos, use the
same interface to seek and
programmatically control the
player view.
So that's how easy it
is to embed videos.
Now of course, what you want
with these videos is for great
full-screen support.
So we have the controls already
on the player view,
and there's a full-screen button
there, and when you
press that button out
the box, it works.
So there's a default
implementation
of full-screen handling.
And the way it's implemented is
that we throw a dialogue on
top of your activity, and we
start playback in that.
So that means you don't need to
perform any additional code
in your application to
get full screen.
But unfortunately, because
we're doing that, it
disconnects the media player,
and we need to reconnect it,
which involves potential
buffering.
And so it's not the most
seamless experience for users.
So our recommended method for
handling full screen is to use
a custom full-screen handler.
So to do that, the only thing
you really need to do is when
full-screen events happen, you
need to react to that by
making sure the player view
expands to fill the full view
hierarchy of your activity.
We then have Helpers
that do almost
everything else for you.
So hiding the System UI,
handling orientation changes,
all that stuff is automatically
handled for you
unless you specify that you
don't want us to handle it
automatically.
And so this provides a really
seamless transition with no
rebuffering, so it's
the best way to
integrate into your apps.
So here's the code here for
handling full-screen.
I'll just go through it in
detail, so I'll hide some of
the extraneous detail.
So the first thing you
need to do is have an
OnFullScreenListener listener.
So here, we're just
implementing the
OnFullScreenListener as part
of the activity itself.
And by doing that, you'll have
to implement the OnFullScreen
method you see below here.
And the library will then call
this OnFullScreen method
whenever the player is
transitioning to full screen.
And so here, what we're doing
is we're saving the full
screen into a field and then
re-laying out the activity.
And to enable this custom
full-screen control, you can
see in onCreate method, we have
player dot enable custom
full-screen helper, which
takes in your
OnFullScreenListener.
So in our case, this.
And so if you see the Do Layout
function here, the only
changes we would need to do in
the Do Layout is if we are
going to full-screen, we have to
set the player view to have
the full size of the view.
So here, we're setting
it to Match Parent.
And we hide all the other UI
elements, so other views,
visibility, [? dot view ?]
[? dot gone. ?]
And so you'd also do this, Do
Layout, whenever you're doing
orientation changes
or otherwise.
So that gives you a brief look
at one of the listeners, the
OnFullScreenListener.
There's a couple of other
listeners for listening to
state of the player itself.
So there's a
PlayerStateListener.
This is a kind of
high-granularity listener for
life cycle events
of the player.
So things like loading a new
video, starting video
playback, ending video playback,
and kind of stopping
video playback or
error events.
There's then another listener
called PlaybackEventListener,
which is a more fine-grained
listener, which listens to
events while playback
is happening.
So things like the users click
Pause, click Resume, or skip
to next video.
So just to give a brief look
at the state transition
diagram for these listeners.
So the PlayerStateListener
runs something like this.
You start in an uninitialized
state, you load a video, you
get an unloading callback.
And between unloading and any
other callback, you can't do
anything with the
video player.
Well, you can't do certain
functions such as checking the
current time of the video or
other functions which would
necessitate knowing what video
is loaded in the player,
because it's not loaded yet.
Once the video has been loaded,
you transition to an
onLoaded callback.
And when this happens, you have
a fully accessible player
available to you.
Now if you're queuing the video,
it'll stop there, until
the user clicks Play.
If you are loading it normally,
it will kind of
auto-transition into playback.
So you then get a call into
either onPlayingAd, if it
starts playing an ad first,
or skips straight to
onVideoStarted.
And when that starts, it'll give
you the video ID that's
currently playing.
And once that video starts, if
you're in the middle of a
playlist, and next and previous
is called, you may
end up back in onLoading state
while it loads the next video.
Or if you finish the playlist,
or you've only got one video
playing, you transition out into
on onEnded, and that's
the end of the state space.
And of course, onError can
happen at any time here.
The second listener, the
PlaybackEventListener, happens
only when video playback
is happening.
So in these two states here,
these events can be firing.
So there's onPlay, onPause, and
onStop, which are called,
as you would expect, when the
user presses Play, Pause,
onStop when the video's ended,
or some other external reason,
stop the video playback.
And then onSkip, if the user
decides to scrub through the
video, it'll tell you where
the user has finished
scrubbing to.
And then there's an onBuffering
callback, which
lets you know that the video is
buffering or stopped buffering.
So there's a bunch more example
code in the API.
Most of it goes through things
which I've discussed here in
the deep dive.
There's also a video wall
example for a bit more of an
idea of what you could
do with the API.
And there's also a bunch of
helper functions for being
able to fire off intents to
the main YouTube App, for
example, to upload a video or
play back a video in the main
YouTube app, as well.
So with that, I'd like
to bring Anton
back up to the stage.
He's going to be doing a live
coding demo to show you how
easy it is to build an app
from scratch with the new
YouTube Player API.
ANTON HANSSON: All right.
Thank you, Ross.
So what I'd like to do is to
create a very simple demo
application from scratch, which
just shows you how easy
it is to get started in YouTube
API, and hopefully how
easy it would be to embed
into your apps, as well.
So I've started here with a
clean Eclipse workspace, which
only has the import library
project, which we distribute
with the API.
So what I'm going to do here is
just to create the new app
project, which will reference
this library project.
Let's see--
I have to add that there, in
the Eclipse preferences.
And second thing we need to do
is to include two permissions
that the library requires,
which is our internet and
network state.
We'll just add them to our
application manifest, as well.
So that's really all the setup
you need to start using the
library here.
As Ross mentioned, we have two
ways of putting a player view
into our hierarchy.
One is the fragment, and one
is just a plain view.
So what I'm going to do here
is just add the plain view.
So I'm adding that here to the
default layout, which is this
linear layout.
I'm going to make it share the
available space here with the
text here above.
So just setting the height here
to 0, and then setting a
weight on this guy.
And I'll do the same
for TextView here.
Add an ID to this guy, as well,
so I can reference him
in the code later.
All right.
So that will be our layout.
Going back to the code, the
first thing you need to do
before interacting with the
library is to initialize the
library with your
developer key.
So what you pass in here is the
context that we're using
and a developer key.
I have my developer
key right here.
Just copy that into our app.
There.
So I'll just pass the
developer key.
Now this is something you
really want to do in a
once-per-app kind of thing.
So in the onCreate of your
application object would be a
good candidate.
But for now, I'll just put
it in the onCreate.
Now I'll want to get a reference
to the player view,
which we have in our hierarchy,
so I'll just use
findViewById here.
And I'll get a reference to
the TextView here as well.
Cool.
And as Ross mentioned, if we use
the player view, we also
need to extend the activity that
we provide, the YouTube
Base Activity, so we can
hook into the life
cycle of the activity.
So I'll just add that here,
YouTubeBaseActivity, and I'll
just register it here.
registerPlayerView,
playerView.
So that's kind of all the
boilerplate you need to start
using this player view.
What I'm going do in this demo
is just to, in the onResume
method, I'll just call
playerView, loadVideo, and
I'll pass in the player video
ID that I specified above.
All right.
So let's try this.
So I've used loadVideo here, so
the expectation is that the
app will start, and the video
will start playing
automatically here.
Whoopsie.
Checking the cable.
There we go.
All right.
It works.
So great.
All right.
So these are controls here.
You can kind of skip back and
forth, and you can pause the
video, and you can toggle the
quality, and use captions, if
they're available,
[INAUDIBLE].
And so the downside of the
full-screen interpretation
becomes obvious here when we
need to kind of rebuffer when
we go into full screen,
which is not ideal.
And so one way to easily improve
this demo would be to
just handle the full screen
event ourselves.
So that's the next thing
I'm going to add here.
So just going out to
the activity again,
and back to the code.
Now, the custom full-screen
thing-- and there's a lot of
things you need to handle when
you do custom full-screen,
like the system UI.
There's a navigation bar,
there's a system bar, there's
all these kinds of automatically
added UI that
you want to get rid of in full
screen, and the orientation
changes are kind of nontrivial
to deal with
correctly, as well.
Luckily, we've done some work
and made it very easy, and we
have a lot of helpers to
help you with that.
So the first thing I want to do
here when enabling custom
full-screen is to make sure that
the view that we play the
video in does not get destroyed
when we change the
orientation to landscape for
the full-screen mode.
So the first thing I'm going
to do here is add to my
manifest that I handle
some configuration
changes on my own.
So the ones that can occur when
we rotate the device are
orientation, keyboardHidden,
and screenSize.
So I'll just add that here, and
we'll make sure that the
view does not get recreated.
And then back in the activity,
we have a helper method called
enableCustomFullScreen.
So this does a lot of things.
It enables all these orientation
changes, listeners
to kind of do what you
want automatically.
The only thing we need to do
is to make sure that the
player view occupies all
the available space.
And our player view will occupy
all the available
space, as long as we just hide
the text view here, because
they are sharing the available
space, so if we get rid of
text view, then that
should be enough.
So we'll just set the
visibility here.
So in the listener here, this
will be invoked when someone
clicks the Full-Screen button.
So we check if, if we have
entered full screen, then we
want to hide the text view.
And if not, then we want to kind
of re-show the text view.
All right.
So I'm going to try launching
this again.
Let's see, switching back.
So the video loading,
just like before.
Clicking the Full-Screen
button takes you into
landscape, and it
keeps playing.
You can start watching the
video in landscape mode.
Rotating, taking it back to
portrait, we'll exit full
screen, as you would expect.
All right.
So very easy, and a quick
demo of what can be
done with the API.
That's all we'll have
time to do today.
Thank you very much,
and back to Ross.
ROSS MCELROY: Thank
you, Anton.
Great job.
So that's all we have
time for today.
So just a quick wrap-up.
A new YouTube Android Player
API is on the way.
It works across a wide variety
of Android devices and it's
been optimized for mobile,
tablet, and Google TV.
It's got support way
back to Froyo.
There's full support for
monetized content, and there's
lots of helper functionality,
as Anton demonstrated, for
making sure you can make
a really polished app.
So we'd like to thank you for
taking the time to join our
session, and if you have any
questions, you can either and
come up to one of the mics or
meet us at the Developer
Sandbox after the talk.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the presentation.
I just wanted to ask, just
regarding the full-screen
mode, I didn't notice, why did
the YouTube video suddenly
become landscape?
I didn't see any code
related to that.
ROSS MCELROY: So the automatic
behavior of the API that we
deal with is, if you handle
configuration changes
yourself, then we know the
video is not going to be
destroyed when orientation
changes.
And so in that case, in either
case, when you press Full
Screen or rotate to landscape,
if you weren't handling that
then, when we rotated it to
landscape, the whole video
would be destroyed,
and it would start
back from the beginning.
AUDIENCE: I guess I understood
that part.
But in that first case, when
you went to full screen, it
had to rebuffer and
everything.
And it remained portrait.
ROSS MCELROY: Exactly.
Because in the first case, Anton
hadn't specified that
we're handling orientation
changes, and so the default
then is not to reorientate
on full-screen changes.
So if he had been in landscape
mode automatically, then it
would have been full screen and
landscape, but we don't
handle that otherwise.
There are flags to enable you to
turn this on or off as you
wish, but that's the kind
of default behavior.
There's also a flag which
enables you to, whenever you
rotate to landscape, to
automatically transition into
full screen.
So if you wanted to create a
portrait app which had no real
landscape UI, but when you
rotated it went to full
screen, you could
use that flag.
And that's actually what is
being used in the I/O
companion app for phones,
but not for tablets.
Thank you.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: So does the API allow
playing multiple videos
in multiple fragments at the
same time, no audio?
ROSS MCELROY: No.
There's only support for
playing one video.
AUDIENCE: But you can select
from the thumbnails.
ROSS MCELROY: You can create
what looks like a player view,
and when the user presses Play,
you can move the player
to that thumbnail and
play back there.
That's what some of our partners
have been doing.
So you could make the appearance
of multiple videos
on a large UI, and then when
the user presses one of the
thumbnails, then playback
happens in that thumbnail,
with one video object.
AUDIENCE: And will we have
a way to customize those
thumbnails, like how they are
presented in a layout?
ROSS MCELROY: We have helper
functions to give you a
thumbnail, but you can also
download the thumbnails from
the data library itself.
So if you were wanting to do
some customization that way,
you could potentially do it
using the data API instead,
though not the customization on
the thumbnails views that
we provide, as far as the
library other than showing a
Play button or not.
Sorry.
At back?
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
The first one, the controls in
the player view, are we able
to customize that?
And also, the Like Video and Add
To Playlist, are they also
in the built-in controls?
ROSS MCELROY: So on your first
question, you can't customize
the controls, but you can
select from a couple of
controls, which we provide.
So there's the default
controls,
which we showed there.
There's a minimized view, where
you just have the red
bar at the bottom, but there's
no other ability to scrub or
anything like that.
Or there's the chromeless
player,
where there's no controls.
We're not allowing customization
of the controls
itself, and you can't overlay
objects on top of the player
view, either.
Your second question was about
and likes and dislikes.
That's not going to be in the
first version of the API.
There is the ability in the
controls themselves to, when
you press the YouTube logo,
that takes you to the main
YouTube app.
And so that would allow users
to like and dislike from the
main YouTube app.
So that would be a workaround.
AUDIENCE: So is it planned to
have that in the future?
ROSS MCELROY: It's a potential
future revision, yes.
We can potentially think about
that, but there's no--
AUDIENCE: Because that would be
really helpful, because the
whole point of having a player
view in our app is that we
don't want to have the user go
to the YouTube app, and that's
not really seamless.
You could have--
ROSS MCELROY: Sure.
That's exactly the reason
we're creating this.
So yeah, it's good feedback.
We'll take that on board and see
what we can do for future
versions of the API.
AUDIENCE: I have one
last question.
So you said that if you want
to use the YouTube player
view, you need to extend
the YouTube activity.
But what if I am already
extending some other
activities in the framework,
like--
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROSS MCELROY: Then
unfortunately, you're going to
have to use the YouTube
player fragment.
So the only option in that case
is to use the fragment or
the support fragment.
If you're using the player
view, you must extend the
YouTube Base Activity.
We need to control the life
cycle of the player, and
that's the only way
we can do it.
AUDIENCE: OK, all
right, thanks.
ROSS MCELROY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right.
One more question.
So in the state machine, there
is a playing ad portion.
So if I choose not to monetize
my application, is there a way
to skip that?
ROSS MCELROY: There's
no way to--
if you choose not to monetize
your application, then you're
going to need to select
non-monetized YouTube videos.
There's no option to turn off
ads for monetized content,
because the content providers
have specified that they want
adverts to be played if
the video's played.
So if you want no ads
to show, only use
non-monetized content.
AUDIENCE: So if I own
the content--
ROSS MCELROY: If you own the
content, you can do whatever
you want with it, yes.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
ANTON HANSSON: Thank
you very much.
ROSS MCELROY: Thanks very
much for your time.